Dave Penman is General Secretary of the
FDA a union which represents workers in
the Civil Service where there's no harm
it's always good to see you thanks for
joining us what did she do wrong in your
opinion well the minister to record is
clear that you have to separate out your
private interests as a minister from
your public duties including the
perception of any conflict of that so a
spinning frame is an entirely personal
matter so if she's asked civil servants
to intervene in any way on that that
would be a breach of the ministerial
code and it's really important because
it means that if something is personal
to swella braveman as an individual
civil servants are not acting on our
behalf and it doesn't look like the
government or the home office is in this
case potentially making a request
um to have a private session in relation
to hospital so people close to the Home
Secretary say that she wasn't asking the
Civil Service to book the course she'd
just gone into the office and said I've
got this flipping parking fine uh
speeding fine how do I book a course
well um if that's the case I'm sure
there's there's no case to answer but
that that's not what is being reported I
think there are questions for the Home
Secretary about what she did and didn't
ask civil servants including a special
advisor if anyone has been tasked a
taxpayer-funded civil servant with our
special advisor or a permanent civil
service to act on her behalf on a
personal matter that's a breach of the
ministerial code now there are clearly
questions about that I'm sure she can
answer that but the only way to clear
this up is an investigation under the
ministerial code to determine whether
there was indeed a breach even if she
did
it's not a biggie is it well it's really
important I think that we separate out
what is our personal interest what if it
was simply the fact that she was
embarrassed and she was actually using
taxpayer-funded civil servants to try to
avoid what everyone else who has a
speeding Fame has to do that would be a
big deal because she'd be abusing her
position these are the questions that
need to be asked because she has our
civil servants to get involved they were
so concerned they raised concerns at the
center of government and they refused
her request now that would not be normal
civil serpenters would not and do not
want to refuse requests of ministers so
it suggests that actually a something of
substance here at the heart of it and
the only way to determine that is an
investigation under the ministerial code
but everybody can have a private um
speed awareness course can't they I I
have no idea but that's a personal well
that's fine she could she can apply for
that personally it is a personal matter
I've I've had a speeding feign I look at
the form I tick the box I don't need
advisors to tell me what to do so the
question clearly is did she abuse her
position and and and what did she ask
civil servants to do the only way to
clear this up is an investigation under
Administration which is an incredibly
busy woman isn't she I mean is it really
that wrong just to say can you just find
out for me sorry can you just find out
for me how to fix that because I'm busy
trying to sort out immigration so civil
servants are publicly funded they're
paid for by you and me they're not there
to support the personal interests of a
minister they don't do the shopping they
don't look after the children and they
don't sort out the speeding thing that's
really important as well they're there
to do to work for you and I this that
any Minister has got personal issues
that they have to deal with and we've
seen other ministers in the home office
who have faced similar situations deal
with it personally themselves
um what do you say to those who say you
know what
um first they came for Dominic Robb they
did for him now they're coming for suela
Braven and your members this is about
ministerial misconduct so it's not about
anyone coming for anyone Dominic Rabb
was found to be a bully by an
independent investigation so Ella
Braverman faces accusations about heart
conduct and whether she's abused her
power that can only be settled by an
independent investigation as well now
the prime ministers decided that he
wants to retain The veto for this which
means it's now his call and his decision
if I was him I'd get an investigation
going quite quickly so we stopped
answering these sorts of questions where
everyone's speculating and we find out
the facts if it's about wasting civil
servants time why would their civil
servants then feel the need to go on and
tell someone about this in high office
rather than just saying no I'm not going
to do that I'm too busy carrying on with
my work and just carry on with her work
but what they will have done it looks
like is they would have decided on that
request they perhaps were concerned
about it and they would then seek could
face either from the permanent secretary
in the home office and then we go to the
cabin office with our specialists in the
proprietary ethics team who advise on
these sorts of conflicts of interest
issues so they've done exactly the right
thing they've got their own code which
says that they cannot further their own
personal interests or their personal
interests of others so potentially if
they've done this either breached their
own code of ethics okay so just to if
there is an investigation and she is
found to have broken the ministerial
code what should happen to her well that
depends the ministry of code allows for
a wrap across the knuckles or
potentially what would you have a
resignation depends what she's found to
have done we don't know it's up to the
Prime Minister the prime minister is the
judge and jury on that he can look and
see how severe if there has been a
breach of the ministerial code is it and
what is the appropriate punishment for
that it used to be it was accepted that
people just resigned that's no change so
if it's a minor breach as we've seen in
the past with other ministers then
essentially they get reprimanded and
there's no dismissal but we need
openness and transparency when it comes
to ministers we don't want ministers
abusing their power or using public
resources for private issues that's not
the way this government and and this
country operates and so that it's really
important when there's suggestions of
that it's fully investigated and it's
transparent what the outcome is okay so
she's found to have asked one of her
team to um sort out a course for her so
she didn't have to be with everybody
else
um what should happen to her the Prime
Minister decides on a punishment on that
I'm not I'm not the Prime Minister I
think but what would your members be
happy with I I think at recognition that
that's wrong it depends how it kind of
egregious that is that she put pressure
on individuals or was it just a mistake
that was made you know she was the
autonomy General this is the ministerial
code she's an experienced Minister all
of those things would be taken in into
account I could find a bit of the code
that she appears to have breached within
a matter of minutes when you go into the
ministerial code that separation of
private and public is quite clear and
it's also quite clear that it's a
personal responsibility of the minister
it's not the job of civil service to
police this so ultimately the Prime
Minister needs to take all of those
things into account deal with the facts
and then make a judgment about what
they're talking about the fact that
she's broken it before
but that may be taken into account you
know I mean the ministerial code
um is there for all ministers she's an
experienced Minister this is a pretty
basic element of it every civil servant
knows that they can't abuse their
position for personal interest you would
have thought that that ministers would
know that as well so again I'm sure
that's what the Prime Minister will take
into account I mean this would all be
better with an independent system it
shouldn't really be for the Prime
Minister and all of this because there's
the potential here that he's making a
political judgment either way
he's asking his independent advisor for
advice the independent advisor cannot
launch an investigation without the
prime minister's permission and the
Prime Minister as a sole Arbiter on the
outcome of that an independent process
would take this completely out of the
Prime Minister sentence and would stop
people accusing people of plain politics
when it comes to these issues to see as
always thanks for explaining that thanks